You already know what a fair value gap
is. You've seen it on the chart. You
know what it looks like. You can even
spot it in seconds, but you are still
losing money. I know because I was
exactly there. And I know because every
single day traders come to me with the
exact same problem. They can spot the
pattern, but spotting it on the chart
and actually making money from it are
two completely different things. What
you see here is a result of building the
right rules around the FVG pattern and
fixing five specific mistakes that most
traders are making right now without
even realizing it. And today I'm going
to show you every single one of them.
Make sure you stay until mistake five
because it's the most devastating one
and it's responsible for years of being
stuck and thousands of dollars being
wasted. Let's go. And before we go into
mistakes, let me show you my system. I
only trade NQ only on the 5-minute time
frame and only on the New York session.
And it has only three rules. Let's jump
into charts and show you exactly what
I'm talking about. Step one is defining
the bias. Every morning before New York
session starts, I check this indicator.
It is simply showing me these three
EMAs. All of them are the 50 period. The
white one is from the 15-minute, the
green one is from the 30-minutes, and
the red one is from the 1-hour time
frame, all displayed directly on my
5-minute chart. I will link the video in
the description on exactly how to set
this up. If price is over at least
1-hour EMA and they are pointing up, I'm
only looking for buys. If price is under
the 1-hour EMA and they are pointing
down, I'm only looking for sells. If
EMAs are flat and too close to each
other and overlapping, I don't trade at
all. This takes literally 5 seconds to
do every single morning to make sure
that I'm in the right side of the
market. Step two, counter trend plus
FVG. Today, as you can see, we are
clearly bullish. Price is over the EMAs
and they are pointing up. I now wait for
the price to pull back against that
bias. That means a bearish counter trend
move. And inside that counter trend, I
need to see a fair value gap. As you can
see here, a bearish fair value gap that
was formed in a bullish day. In some
cases, I'll also watch previously
unmitigated FVGs from earlier in the
same day. If price inverse them cleanly
with a confirmed bias, it's a lower
probability setup, but it works on
directional days. For this example, the
FVG is here. That is where I'm watching.
I don't enter yet. I don't touch
anything. I'll just wait. And there
where step three comes. If we inverse
the fair value gap, that means if we
break back through this bearish fair
value gap in the direction of my bias,
that's where I enter. I either put my
stop loss under the candle which broke
the FVG or the swing low. And my target
will be the previous liquidity. And if
it's not giving me at least two Rs, I
simply target two Rs. Now, let's play
this trade out.
And TP hit. And if you are completely
new to my system and want the full
breakdown from scratch, I link the
complete tutorial in the description
down below. And now let me talk about
the five mistakes that stops most
traders from making this work.
Everything I'm about to show you came
directly from my comment section and
also from my Instagram DMs. Mistake
number one is trading when the EMAs are
flat and mixed. You can see here on the
chart that the EMAs have no direction,
not pointing anywhere, and people still
trade markets like this. This is the
most expensive mistake on this list and
it explain almost every losing streak
people have when they try this setup.
The FVG is just a pattern. It appears
when the conditions are good or bad.
That means if you are looking for the
pattern first, then checking the bias
second, you will take trades in
conditions where the setup has no edge
whatsoever. There is no directional
bias. The market has no clear intent.
Any FVG you see here is meaningless.
This is a no trade day. This is a stay
out day. Mistake number two is entering
in the middle of the candle. You can
clearly see here that we inverted this
fair value gap. Let's imagine that we
put our stop loss right here and put our
TP at two hours. But the problem with
this is this 5-minute candle is not over
yet. That means it didn't close yet.
Let's just run the price.
And voila, you didn't wait for the
candle to be over and the price went
against you immediately. That means
never never enter a trade before the
5-minute candle is completely over. Now,
for mistake number three. I see so many
traders placing their stop loss right at
the FVG. Let me show you some example
from past days to know exactly where you
need to place your stop loss. There are
four places where you can place your
stop loss. At the inversion candle, at
the previous candle,
at the swing high or swing low, or at
the FVG. You already know that the stop
loss is not a suggestion. It must be
placed at the exact point where the
setup is no longer valid. So, on today's
trade, it made sense placing the stop
loss under the FVG and under the
inversion candle. Simply because this
was a strong momentum candle. So, we are
well protected by the FVG and also by
the inversion candle. If the price comes
back to this point, the setup will no
longer be valid. You can see that I did
the same thing here. This was a trade
from yesterday. Here you can see that I
placed my stop loss at the previous
candle simply because the inversion
candle was not a strong momentum candle.
Even if I placed my stop loss at the
swing low, the stop loss would be
inevitable for this day. This is the
reality of trading. Here you can also
see that I placed my stop loss under the
inversion candle because it's simply
have strong momentum. Here you can see
that I placed my stop loss right after
FVG because this was a strong momentum
candle and I usually, depending on
market conditions, I usually don't
exceed 300 to 350 ticks per stop loss.
But you don't need to take this as a
rule because in some market phases we
have bigger candles we can exceed, for
example, 300 ticks and sometimes we have
smaller candles and we can reduce our
stop loss size. And now for the last
example, you can see right here that I
placed my stop loss at the swing low
the previous candle simply
because this was not a strong momentum
candle and the setup will no longer be
valid if we exceed this level right
here. That's why make sure to place your
stop loss always at the logical place
and always define your contract number
before entering a trade to risk always
the same amount. Now for mistake number
four, I see some traders buying under
the EMAs and selling over the EMAs. This
is simply not how the setup works. We
always buy when we are over at least the
one hour EMA and we always sell we are
at least below the one hour EMA. Never
buy under the EMAs or sell over the
EMAs. Now we came to the last and the
most devastating mistake that traders
make. It's revenge trading and FOMO.
This is what keep traders stuck for
years. They can master the strategy but
the problem isn't in the strategy. In
fact, 80% of my success didn't came from
the strategy. It came from removing
these two things. And this is the one
nobody wants to admit. I get it. I
sincerely get it. You get stopped out,
it hurts. Then you watch NQ move 200
points in the direction that you
predicted at the beginning, just past
your stop. Your anger kicks in, you jump
back in with bigger size this time
because you want to recover right now.
You get stopped out again, you enter,
and you go deep down in this vicious
cycle. This is where you blow 20 funded
accounts, where you blow all your
capital, and you lose thousands of
dollars and years from your life, simply
because you didn't accept the loss. Or
you're sitting on the sidelines, you
skip the setup because the conditions
weren't clean, NQ starts running,
everyone online posting their wins, your
FOMO takes over, you chase the move at
the worst possible entry, and price
reverses immediately. Both of these have
nothing to do with the pattern. You know
my system like the back of your hands,
you know what the fair value gap looks
like, you know the rules, you even
watched all my videos. The problem is
none of this matters when you are
sitting in front of the charts with real
money moving against you, and your
emotions are making every single
decision. And I will completely be
honest with you. This is something no
YouTube video will ever fix, not this
one, not any other one. But let me show
you what eliminating these mistakes,
especially these two, actually looks
like. 257k
with almost 75% win rate in the last 4
months, taking only one trade per day,
following my rules every single day. And
I'll be honest with you. I still deal
with the urge to revenge trade after a
loss. I still feel the FOMO when NQ has
moved 200 points and I didn't catch that
whole move. The difference is I don't
act on it anymore. That is what separate
this from where most traders are stuck.
It's not a better pattern. It's not a
better strategy. Just a better execution
of a simple one. Now, be honest with
yourself. How many of those mistakes are
you making right now? Because these are
just the most common ones. The mistakes
specific to how you trade, your entries,
your exits, the exact moment you break
your rules. And now, let me be real with
you. You know the setup, you know the
rules, you just watch the mistakes. But,
knowing and executing are two completely
different things. And if you're still
not consistent, the gap will not close
by watching another video. This is what
my one-on-one mentorship fixes. We go
through your actual trades together,
your specific execution problems, your
psychology, the revenge trading, the
FOMO, the moments you break your rules
under pressure. I hold you accountable
every single day, so the rules you know
you should follow, you actually follow
them when real money is on the line.
It's not a course. It's not a group.
Just you and me working directly on
everything that is stopping you from
being profitable. If you are serious
about making this work, the link to
apply is in my description below. And
spots are very limited. Now, drop a
comment telling me which mistakes have
you been making. I read and I respond to
every single one. Make sure to like the
video, subscribe. Let's meet on the next
one.